hey guys it is the first public day of
III and you might think the user stopped
but it's still rolling
it sure is you got a real bad attitude
for thinking that come down sorry sorry
anyway here's what happened today
Pokemon go has an anniversary event that
started today good news for those of you
who might be stuck in long III lines the
Solstice event kicks off today at 1:00
p.m. Pt and there a heap of bonuses feed
a nab until June 20 there are increased
encounter rates for everyone's favorite
Fire & Ice
type Pokemon and their evolutions
including Charmander cyndaquil pounder
sweater and Sneasel surely one of those
is a fake name
Shirley nope there's bonus xp to earn
for sweet throws and curveballs and
lucky eggs are half off in the in-game
shop Pokemon go we'll also be holding a
real world event to celebrate its
anniversary on July 22nd in Chicago's
Grant Park tickets for the event go on
sale June 19 destiny 2's Game Director
Luke Smith has confirmed that the game
will run at 30 frames per second on Xbox
one X the same as ps4 Pro some believed
destiny too will be running high on Xbox
one X since Microsoft's new console
packs in more power than the ps4 Pro but
it appears that's not the case
presumably Bungie wants to ensure that
the experience runs the same across the
standard and more powerful consoles PC
however will have uncapped frame rates
we also have a release date for the PC
version of October 24 while the console
release has been moved up to September 6
while we're talking Xbox one X some
analysts believe the most powerful
console ever made is two XE Penn's AC
Penn's
XE pants expensive sorry justjust they
say it's too expensive games industry
dot beers collected the opinions of
several analysts and many agree the
price may inhibit the console from
achieving wide success Michael Pachter
of Wedbush security said a consumer
could buy both the s and the ps4 for the
cost of an X so it makes it a tough
decision for anyone whose budget
conscious or constrained I think it will
resonate well with the wealthy few who
buy it but think it's too expensive
while IDC researchers Louis Ward says
Xbox
and X is remarkably affordable given its
specs personally I'm interested to see
how many parents unwittingly buy their
kids Xbox one SS when they meant to buy
them Xbox one X's let me know which one
you thought I said first in the comments
below
finally if you have 800 bucks lying
around and an assassin's Creed tattoo
you're probably exactly the person this
next story is going to appeal to among
its various special editions that have
already been announced a mighty dawn of
the Creed legendary Edition has arrived
for Assassin's Creed origins and it
costs 800 bucks total bar oh my god it
comes with a gold steelbook case the
season pass a twenty eight point seven
inch statue of the main character by yak
a world map for lithographs the
soundtrack and art book art cards and an
eagle amulet only 999 of these
presumably massive boxes will be
available worldwide so it's also pretty
limited but is it worth 800 bucks
you be the judge that is everything
we've got for you today so do let us
know down in that comment box what's
excited you about e3 today and don't
forget to grab the game spot now app on
iOS and Android to get the top ten news
stories of the day delivered right to
your phone thus you never like point on
this hallway didn't say tomorrow at that